au début j'avais pensé vous emmener à la
campagne pas très loin à moins de 100 km
enfin 100 km après huit semaines de
confinement c'est un petit peu une
expédition
[Musique]
c'est peut-être un peu beaucoup là
et puis en faisant le tour de mon jardin
je me suis dit qu'on allait y rester
encore un peu
il s'y déroule en ce moment un phénomène
extraordinaire
vous entendez ce bourdonnement sa butine
c'est comme ça depuis plusieurs jours
c'est un ca note
certains disent aussi 1 lille 2 quel
iphone
il a un peu souffert l'été dernier avec
la canicule mais bon il est quand même
fait de belles fleurs les abeilles la
donne elles viennent en priorité sur cet
arbuste c'est normal elles sont attirées
par le bleu depuis une quinzaine
d'années on sait que c'est la seule
couleur à laquelle elles sont sensibles
ce qui est très étonnant c'est que cette
couleur n'est pas la plus répandue dans
le monde végétal si vous regardez bien
autour de vous vous verrez davantage de
fleurs oranges jaunes ou blanches que de
fleur bleue pendant longtemps les
scientifiques se sont demandés comment
les abeilles repérer les fleurs d'une
autre couleur que le bleu maintenant ils
savent en observant de très très près
des pétales ils ont constaté qu'il était
strié à cause de ces stries la lumière
est diffracté les différentes couleurs
qui composent la lumière blanche sont
séparées les unes des autres
on ne le voit pas les abeilles oui pour
vous donner une petite idée de ce
qu'elle voit on obtient le même effet
avec un cd en jouant avec la lumière
[Musique]
et bien c'est irisation des pétales
génère un halo de lumière autour des
fleurs qui contient du bleu qui attire
le regard des abeilles qui se
précipitent vers des fleurs dont elle
ignore la couleur réel enfin réel la
couleur que nous ne nous voyons me
retombe
[Musique]
elle se régale
elle se gave de nectar et font le plein
de pollen qu'elle rassemble sur leurs
pattes arrière et surtout en allant de
fleur en fleur elle dépose le pollen de
lune sur le pistil de l'autre et
participent ainsi activement mais
involontairement à la pollinisation donc
à la reproduction des plantes
on estime que 35 % de ce que nous
mangeons est liée à l'activité des
insectes et il ya du monde là-dedans pas
que des abeilles domestiques
il est aussi des bourdons et des
abeilles sauvages elles sont plus
petites que leurs cousines domestiques
elles sont solitaires et vivent dans des
petits chats creuse ou sous l'écorcé
d'arbre mort ou encore dans les
anfractuosités de sol ou de la roche du
coup tout hôtel raison droit one 100 km
à l'est à très bientôt pour une nouvelle
capsule 2d confiné longo
[Musique]